the Joe Rogan experience I've never felt
more pressure my life to come up with
new become a better comic than when I
released my special of course I'm like
oh [ __ ] now now the work starts that was
whatever do you have the works don't
ever satisfy with myself more than like
15 20 minutes a week 15 minutes where I
was I couldn't tell you was I've seen 20
minutes a week I'll have a glass of wine
I'll put my feet up I'll kick back and
then that little voice in the back of my
head it's like are you doing everything
you can do get up come on kind of a [ __ ]
and of a demon though is Joe like I
represent like my one of my dreams was
to buy the car that I bought and I
bought it we're in bed my girl goes how
do you feel it exactly the same like I
think what you like material things they
don't matter at all and then they say we
wake up might might get out with my son
every morning and we always watch cars
on YouTube and she was what the watching
a different car she goes what the [ __ ]
you're doing like looking in the next
car she's like there's no way I'm like I
need I need goals yeah Suze we bought a
bottle house I swear to God the next
morning she was what are you doing truly
Oh looking at the next house I don't
know what to do no that's not my message
to dust it was enjoy but don't get the
thing about stuff though as opposed to
like goals is like stuff you could
always just keep buying stuff and make
you money to buy stuff and then you find
yourself being one of those people that
just does stuff for money because you
want to buy the stuff I've never done
that but there are people like that out
there right you know I've heard Steve
Harvey talk about money like how much
money he wants to make per year and and
someone was making fun of it and I was
thinking well he's in this vibe where
he's trying to get stuff and and make
money and you got to make money to get
stuff and you get sort of in this game
of accumulating more and bigger and
better things for me the most important
thing is the stuff that I put out if
people like it because I do a podcast if
I do a UFC and I suck if I stumble
through something or I make a bad call
or it's not that [ __ ] will [ __ ] be up
for days and there's nothing to do
nothing I can do to fix it you know
amber Guinea Ferrari it's like there's
nothing I wouldn't do a damn thing
so what's saying with a podcast if I do
a podcast that doesn't go well if I do a
set the set doesn't go well or stumble
through a joke all I care about is the
stuff that I do in terms of like agree
like progress I saw my progress and that
I'll distract myself with stuff but like
like just watch cross like 50 bucks or
something I don't know
yeah I've been Tyler that's a Taser not
50 it's like 300 bucks maybe you know
I'm saying but it doesn't matter whether
they're 500 or 300 bucks or this is 22
grand not a big deal 22 grand
does it matter American money gasps
don't call cash no big deal Rolex
talking yeah it's [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
just talking [ __ ] it's like but no
platinum Rolex
my point is is it's like that doesn't
make you happy does make you feel anyway
this gonna make me feel anyway none of
it the more I learned the more I
accumulate these material things it
doesn't mean that nothing that means
[ __ ] is your friends and your loved ones
and what you're trying to do with your
life Bob Dylan said it best he said they
said you know what's what's success to
you he goes not having to work for
[ __ ] and waking up going to bed
doing exactly what I want yeah boom she
already doing no I'm already doing that
yeah the only time I ever felt
I guess somewhat successful I'd really
don't but the only time so I felt a
little successful is when I turned down
a big gig on a major Network to do TV I
went mmm no I'm kind of good man I'm
good doing what I want to do and I own
all this stuff and I don't I don't find
that press to do it do you imagine what
would be like if you had a boss remember
the [ __ ] that you guys were dealing with
at Fox we were telling you to stop
cursing on the fighter and the kid all
areas just imagine how bad that advice
is think about how many [ __ ] millions
of downloads of the fighter and the kid
have been out there how many humans on
the planet earth have you could see the
overhead map of all the people on the
planet a light went off every time I
dude was listening to the fighter in the
kid like holy [ __ ] it would freak you
out and see that number and that fox guy
was like first clean it up wife you know
what that guy told me to I started
arguing with him and he kind of got my
face went just like you have your black
belt in the Octagon I got my black belt
in TV no it's cool the [ __ ]
and did he really say that he's got his
black belt in TV let me tell you he got
fired from Fox mother of course you did